tonight we begin a new series on
children and the culture our focus this
evening the movement towards putting
more risk in kids playtime to make their
lives safer down the road
here's correspondent Allison barber some
call this a junk or a risk playground
others call it an adventure playground
these kids just call it fun what do you
like about the junk playgrounds origins
traced back to Denmark during World War
two when a landscape architect first
conceived the idea they started looking
at where are the children playing and he
found that wherever there was rubble
from the war bombed buildings or
whatever that's where children were
playing the idea spread throughout
Europe today there are risk playgrounds
in places like Germany Belgium England I
don't think it's good for them to learn
consequences of risks that they take I
think it's good for them to have a go at
new things this is London's Glomus
adventure playground the place is
changing all the time
kids get to do things they want to do
there's a similar one in Berkeley
California we have eight now in the US
but supporters say eight is not enough
the most dangerous thing you can do to a
child is raise them where they don't
know how to risk assess but that has to
be cultivated and this kind of adventure
play really cultivates it but is it too
dangerous the CDC says every year US
emergency rooms treat more than 200,000
children under the age of 15 the
playground related injuries I do think
it's important for kids to encounter
some risk and to as they're developing
to learn how to make good decisions and
to deal with challenges and risks I
think one of the issues with this type
of playground is that the environment is
such that if a child does fall which
they fall all the time when they're out
playing they're gonna fall that's just
part of their growth and development
that they're gonna have more serious
injuries
potential benefits are hard to quantify
but supporters of these types of
playgrounds say children aren't just
playing and learning how to be stronger
individuals and better adults they're
not given a chance to build their
confidence to face risk and realize oh I
have the courage and the strength to
take this on I know how to work with
others I know how to problem-solve we
over protect our kids by always watching
them and not giving them the opportunity
to practice the values and principles
that we already instill in them in
Colorado a Denver nonprofit tested these
playgrounds they hosted pop-up events to
see if kids actually liked them a
permanent one called free range
playground is set to open this summer
right fascinating Ellison thank you our
series continues tomorrow what do you
think drop me a line on Twitter about
that